When we analyzed a single
particle motion-- say,
we have an object, which
is moving with momentum p--
then we have two principles.
Our Newton's second law told
us that the force on the object
causes the momentum to change.
And now, what we'd like to do
is consider another principle.
Suppose we're looking
at some point about s.
We'd like to show that
the torque about s
is equal to the change
in angular momentum
of the particle about s.
So let's now investigate that.
Well, recall that angular
momentum is defined
to be about a point, a
vector s, and will indicate m
to show that this is the
vector from s to where
the object is located cross
the momentum of the object.
And what we want
to now calculate
is the time derivative
of that quantity.
Well, when you take the time
derivative of a vector product,
it's the product rule.
And so there's two terms here.
It's drs/mdt cross p
plus rsm cross dp/dt.
Now, no matter what
the point s is,
the derivative of
the vector that's
measuring where s to
the mass is is always
the velocity of the object.
So that's the velocity.
And momentum is just
mass times the velocity.
And you can see that
that quantity is 0
because a vector direct
product with its cross product
with itself is 0.
And this second term--
notice that we
have dp/dt in here.
And it's always crucial
to understanding
these calculations where
the second law comes in.
This is just rsm cross f.
And recall that when we
talk about the torque
on an object about the
point s by the action
of, say, some force.
And so suppose we had a
force acting on this object.
And that's going
to cause the object
to change its direction
by some amount delta p.
Then the torque, by definition,
is rsm cross the force.
And we see that that is exactly
equal to the change in angular
momentum.
And so for a single particle,
the torque about a point
s causes the angular momentum
about that point to change.
And this result will generalize
for a collection of particles
in a calculation
that's very simple.